des plages désertes des terrasses vide
des hôtels fermés barricadé autrefois
vivante et animée
les stations balnéaires de tunisie
compte aujourd'hui au ralenti
tout s'est arrêté en juin dernier
lorsqu'un terroriste armé de fusils
mitrailleurs s'est introduit dans ce
grand hôtel de sousse et ya tué 38
personnes
c'est un choc c'est vraiment c'est une
tragédie mais reste ça dit le directeur
de l'hôtel impérial marhaba se
trouvaient sur place le jour du drame
une page difficile à tourner pour lui et
tous les employés
on peut pas l'effacer mais on essaie de
vivre avec et on doit se lever de
nouveau on n'a pas d'autre choix
l'hôtel impérial marhaba est aujourd'hui
fermé et nul ne sait quand il rouvrira
les séquelles de l'attentât sont aussi
économiques
si toutes les victimes ici étaient des
touristes étrangers
la cible visée était bien la tunisie car
l'industrie touristique est l'un des
premiers secteurs de l'économie ici elle
représente près de 7 % du pib
selon les autorités tunisiennes le
manque à gagner pour le pays en 2015 se
chiffre en milliards de dollars sur les
plages de sousse on trouve désormais des
policiers armés les zones balnéaires
sont maintenant beaucoup mieux protégé
partout le niveau de sécurité a été
rehaussée mesure peine à rassurer
les autorités britanniques déconseille
toujours à leurs ressortissants de venir
en tunisie alors beaucoup de grossistes
ont retiré la destination de leur
catalogue
de l'avis de tous l'année qui débute
s'annonce encore plus difficile que
celle qui vient de se terminer
marcel fourati qui a ouvert un des
premiers hôtels à hammamet dans les
années 60 n'a jamais rien vu de tel
il n'y a pas de réservation du tout
c'est ça qui est encore plus grave
moi je pense 2016 c'est déjà terminé
il faut penser à 2017 2018
pour survivre les hôteliers se replie
sur la clientèle locale
les algériens les tunisiens et sur les
quelques clients étrangers fidèles qui
reviennent de même année après année
comme pâquerettes au sens de gatineau
qui en est à son quatrième séjour elle a
prévu rester ici deux mois et ne
s'explique pas la crainte selon l
irrationnel vis-à-vis de la tunisie
je sais ça inquiète beaucoup de gens
mais moi ça me fait pas peur je trouve
ça triste pour la tunisie puis un chiot
que ça la peau sa raison d'être
une impression d'injustice largement
partagé ici les attaques de paris elle
était beaucoup beaucoup plus dangereuse
que celle de sauce alors pourquoi
pénaliser seulement la tunisie le
directeur de l'hôtel mövenpick le gros
de sousse avec ses 1200 lits a dû se
résoudre à mettre à pied la moitié de
ses 600 employés dans l'attenté d'une
éventuelle reprise
une reprise que personne s'il va venir
avant longtemps
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
sousse en tunisie